good evening everybody and welcome to
the south eastern area planning
committee meeting and how lovely to have
a full house tonight
thank you all for turning out
um i'm vanessa bell and i'm the chairman
of this committee members we are
streaming the meeting live as well as
recording and by being present in the
meeting you are giving your consent to
being recorded during each item please
put your hand up to indicate if you wish
to speak i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
please note that the youtube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microphones therefore
can i ask that when invited to speak you
remember to turn your microphone on and
then turn it off when finished please
reference a page or paragraph number
when referring to the agenda papers and
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and advise that in the event of a fire
please use the fire exits marked with
the green running mat
all right now we don't have any produce
for absence burner so uh we can move on
to item three the minutes
it's recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on 12th of january 2022
found on pages 7 to 10 are approved as a
true and accurate record
why so move do you have a second thank
you counselor
can we agree that
yeah
any
any matters of accuracy anyone wishes to
raise councillor duik
uh
chairman um
it it's only relevant and it's mentioned
in the minutes of that meeting but
two meetings ago we deferred a decision
on
red lion's farm at
lexington
for further information it still has not
come back
and that's three if not four months ago
what on earth are they doing with it
can we mimic that please some
burner and none
yeah find out what's happening with that
thank you for reminding us of that
councillor joint must admit it had
slipped my mind can't say madam chairman
in light of councillor duke's questions
in your request a minute do you think we
could have an answer circulated around
to all the committee
um because a number of us have wondered
whether applications got to us i think
if an answer can be given and we're all
made aware
um yes
super could we all have an answer to
that
thank you chairman i mean i mean i'm
surprised cancer channel didn't mention
it but
surely we must be in the realms of
non-determination as well so you would
have thought that we could we could have
well over the 28 days whatever that's
unless unless the applicants agreed to
that we could be in a difficult position
but i think cancer duke's absolutely
right i mean you know this committee
asked it to come back in four weeks and
i guess that would have been eight weeks
ago was it at least so that's very good
so you know
need information circulating please
thank you
so we're agreeing the minutes are we not
um i said that's super thank you very
much
item four declarations of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
pecuniary interests or non-pecuniary
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regards paragraph
six to eight inclusive of the code of
conduct for members any
counselor
uh yeah thank you chairman just that i'm
a member of essex county council which
are normally console it's not curing it
doesn't look so they have been on this
application thank you council messenger
thank you madam chairman um john
mccoonery um michael lewis was the
architect who built my house
and i'll just remind cancer schools
yes
i think many of us do
um my own rights members that um
you are required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they become
become
i cannot speak
as soon as you become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
so that brings us to the main item of
business item five which is zero zero
zero three five full
temperance house 22 high street burnable
crouch
this agenda item is found on pages 11 to
18 there is no members update on this
item tonight
we have one public participant the
applicant mrs thornton
so i'm going to head over to you the
saddler please to present the report
thank you thank you chairman
this application seeks full planning
permission for the reinstatement of a
rooftop rooftop belvedere to temperance
house to serve the second floor
apartments
the application site is located
on the northern side of the high street
and located within the center of burnham
crouch town centre and the burnham
conservation area
the site is occupied by a three-story
mixed-use building comprising of a cafe
restaurant to the ground floor and
residential apartments on the first and
the second floor
the application
this is this location plan
the site outlined in red
and the block plan shows the position of
the proposed belvedere on the roof of
the building
so the application is a resubmission of
a previously refused application the
submitted scheme has been reduced by
size
with a 0.6 meter reduction in the width
and 0.2 meter reduction to the eaves
height and 0.2 meter reduction in the
overall height the proposed materials
have also been changed from part glazed
part grey finish sink panels with
anthrax and anthracite coloured steel
frames
with standing steel grey roof sink roof
to clear
and clear double glazed in black metal
frames for wall for the walls and this
and standing seam gray sink roof
so the first plan is the proposed
elevations of the current application
shows the north and the west
elevations
the
next slide
is the north and west elevations on the
previously refused application
we have the proposed south and east
elevations on the current proposed
application
and the south and east elevations on the
previously refused scheme
this is the proposed rooftop elevation
so how it would sit on top of the roof
of the current um
submitted application
and this is the rooftop elevations of
the previously refused scheme
the existing and proposed roof plan of
the current application
the
existing and proposed roof plan of the
previously refused application
so we do have some photographs so this
is a photo montage that was supplied by
the agent mike lewis and to give us an
idea of what the belvedere would look
like within the street scene
of burnham on crouch
and these are some photographs taken
recently
this view was from the clock tower
within the high street
this was the view from the sea wall
directly opposite the sites
had some photos from the war memorial
this was outside the start in public
house
and these photos were taken outside
questions from curtis o'boyle travel
agent and estate agents which is just a
number of buildings down from the
application sites
there i also there are also some photos
from the roof of the building so this is
what is in existence at the moment on
the roof and the access from the stairs
is taken from the apartment with the
slide a sliding roof to get access to
the roof
these are some photos of the views from
various points within the
from the roof of the of temperance house
from all directions from the sea down
towards the high street where the clock
tower is the opposite end of the high
street and where the neighboring
properties are in relation to this site
i also have some
drawings that were supplied by tim and
by the agent of what the previous
belvedere looked like back in the early
well around about this 19th century when
the
site was a hotel
so there's a small belvedere to the roof
and tim has
mocked up and the agent have mocked up
another view of what the proposed
belvedere may look like when it's in
situ
and they are not to scale and they're
not architecturally correct they're just
an idea of what it might look like from
the roadside
and that was the end of the
photos
thank you thank you so much for that so
um
as i said we do have a speaker so um mrs
hilton if i can mr filter
i could ask you um you have two minutes
so if we could have the
not wherever you feel comfortable
wherever there's a free mic you can just
pop pop your mic on and um
when you're ready we will go
okay
thank you chairman and members and good
evening my name is dee thornton i am the
applicant of this scheme and my husband
and i are both long-term residents in
burnham
we both run successful small businesses
within the town and temperance house is
our permanent home
this is a repeat application reduced in
height and width as the response to the
previous delegated refusal
both the original scheme and this
current application have been supported
by burnham town council as well as by
modern's own conservation officer
council bell has kindly called in the
application due to what we see as an
irrational recommendation to refuse once
again
the grounds for the recommendations are
based only on policy for which the
subjective opinion of single officers
stands no black and white guidance is
being challenged
if it were not within the conservation
area we believe that this application
would pass straight through and yet with
the blessing of the conservation officer
it remains opposed the rooftop extension
is shown within the application
documents to be invisible from all but
the east elevation of the high street
and from which the view carefully mimics
historic belvedere we stood in the exact
same place on the rooftop
we have provided some helpful mock-ups
of the belvedere's appearance which
demonstrates an accurate representation
of the reduced height and width proposal
and design now fully glazed to reflect
the original belvedere design
i only ask that you view our proposals
objectively and hope that you share the
view of the conservation officer that
the scheme is a sympathetic addition to
the building and skyline and preserves
the character of the conservation area
and recommend the proposals be approved
thank you chairman thank you so much
well within the time thank you miss
filter
so i don't know mr taylor do you have
anything to add before we throw the
floor out into memphis
um no please uh you're welcome to the
debate
thank you thank you
can i ask a question for just for
clarity but then i'll happily give way
to the ward members and if the officer
confirmed did mr house and support the
original
application because i i think that's
quite important to understand that yes
he did
yes
yes could we go back to the picture of
the 1900s
conservatory
now
that to me looks really elegant and
beautiful
and the new version doesn't look
so much
my feeling is that uh it would be really
lovely if they stuck to that
and then everybody would be happy it's a
conservation area clearly conserving
and that would make me happy
thank you
anybody else
counselor
counselor fluka okay um yeah i know i've
known this building for donkey's years
like most of us i mean i remember going
to a party on the route without the
parapet in the uh in the mid-1970s there
you go when chris petrie are in the
building um i mean it's quite an
interesting one i mean look you you've
heard me before
you know talk to tim howson's knowledge
and
his advice to this planning committee
um
my only real concern about this is
is really the materials and and i just
think
that you know it is quite an elegant
building this when you look at it on its
own and i just think sort of putting
something up there that's got black
fenestrations that are aluminium i'm not
sure that's the right thing to do so if
we were minded if we were minded to
approve this and and you know
i do support this application bar this
one point i would prefer to see the
fenestrations uh in a white color
preferably in timber and i know people
will say well look okay it's quite an
exposed location you know what's the
maintenance going to be but if you do it
for mccoy and which i'm sure everybody's
familiar with
it's got a life span of 50 years would
you believe and it's used extensively
now in the construction industry and
once it's painted and painted properly
it seems to last forever and it can have
its zinc move so chairman i i think with
the caveat on conditions and the fact
that maybe the applicant thought about
using timber rather than aluminium
fenestrations i i would say
uh chairman i propose that uh contrary
to the officer's recommendation we
actually approve this application thank
you i think i see a second in hand from
counselor hell i'm going to go to
counselor shanna now
hand as well so that's okay
um
well
my view is
having really unless there's a wider
response that highlights some issues
the conservation officer i noticed had
no objections
so bearing that in mind um
and i i paid great regard mr uh mr house
and rather nothing against the officer's
recommendation but to me
had there been something from mr helson
sort of highlighting something that
might have altered my thinking but if mr
halsam feels there's no objection that
means across the whole
application that means i must assume the
materials as well so perhaps could i
just ask was there any caveats or
indication in mr helsing's response
saying you know something might be
better done another way but still
carried no objections or was it just a
straight no objection really
so
mr halsen said he had no objection to
the approval and uh did not advise any
any specific conditions
that's good enough for me madam chairman
thank you thank you council stamp then
council
yeah i actually think it's fine uh i
mean um many people have been for drinks
when it was the temperance bar and
everything there
and many people actually wanted to put
um
balustrade and railings up there so they
could have a disco and a party well no
just going them days
and
and to be honest i looked at it and
excuse me councilman luca
we do know
um so chairman i i actually agree with
the proposal from councillor fluke and
seconded
and i think it's going to look really
super it's not doing anybody any harm
it's i mean i can point some horrors out
in our conservation area if we want to
um but i won't and i think it should be
supported and i think it's really good
that they're actually living and
enjoying burnham to its best and and
contributing to our fantastic town so i
think it's great thank you chairman and
it's bringing something back that was
there before so councillor jurick
yeah thank you madam chairman um
i'd be not quite happy to support this
the thing that i find strange though is
that um
i do not i don't understand why planning
officers would object to something like
this in the conservation area when the
conservation officer has very clearly
said that he is happy to support it and
in fact supported the previous design
um i mean as far as materials go as
cancer fluke rates point i mean surely
we can do that under conditions if we're
mindful to approve it
but
i mean i'm quite you know i'm not i'm
not going to get too fussed about it i
mean it's up up in the air there
nobody's going to see what the uh
materials are from a distance so i'm
quite happy
either way but
if we did want to change materials then
surely conditions can do that thank you
chairman thank you um
council fluke again yeah chairman i i
mean i don't you know i don't want to
make this a precursor of what's going to
be given as planning permission but you
know i think we should if we are mindful
to approve this we should put the
standard conditioning over materials
just to make sure but chairman i don't
want to tease the applicant and say that
i might change my mind with my proposal
but can bearing in mind where this is
located i know that
in the volt in in the body of the report
um there's been no objections for
anybody but can the officer just confirm
that the um the planning notice was
fixed properly and it was advertised
thank you
yes second i can answer that question
there were two site notices put up
um and they were in in perfect um
existence to where the property is there
was one i think at the end of chapel
road i think it might have been and one
just slightly along the on the site
itself so it was it was um clearly
advertised for all to see
well i know that the conservation area
hasn't stipulated anything about
materials it's impossible to tell from
those pictures what the original
belvedere was actually made from
um i am sure that
[Music]
well i know that the applicants care
about the conservation area and i know
that they're committed to preserving and
you know
reinstating
something that uh that was so um
we have a proposal which is to um
go against the office for recommendation
and to approve
but with a condition around materials
and that is seconded
do you want to change that no and just
the normal conditions that we'd normally
yeah conditions just so that we get it
right but i mean cancer duke quite
rightly just whispered in my ear and
take his thunder but um it's quite
likely that that could have been cast on
and would have come from burnham foundry
um but it's just trying to get something
up there that's nice we
yeah i sort of pick up on that so i'm
sure they're listening to what what
we're saying you know which we look i
think it's a great scheme but it looks
it needs to look nice and i don't know
if anyone can remember the old belvedere
and the lawns at the other end but i
mean that's a beautiful house down there
they knocked down with the belvedere i
remember it as a child and uh yeah i'm
gonna stop before you before you get too
deep into reminiscences there councillor
flynn cameron
as i said to the
as i say
i i love a belvedere i couldn't see at
least two from my uh office window in my
house burnham lots of belvedere we even
have an estate called belvedere so um
let's go to the vote members so those in
favor of fun supporting this application
please raise your hands
and those against
that's one council of schools so um with
the majority and with the usual
conditions some
application is approved
can i uh just confirm the
conditions that we would be
we would be attached in the normal
conditions in terms of time limit
um
yes
yeah i'm just confirming that
super
thank you everybody now one
item six any other items of business
that the chairman decides are urgent and
there is
members i'm proposing
proposing
that this southeast planning meetings
return to burnham i'm hoping that's a
seconding hand there
members can we vote please
jeremy can i can i just say something is
it at all possible to him that we could
maybe revert back to
mondays because it seemed to work
debuting on monday
monday's work quite well it works with
me
um you know it seems funny having a
meeting on the wednesday because it
means my weekend starts today early well
i'll be having that council of lucas so
members i propose
um for me that doesn't actually work i'm
chairman i'm afraid and i'm not trying
to be difficult but if i'm the only one
and i'm the only one but
no i'm thinking about tennis coaching
actually
remember it does work for me um as the
chair so i might pull chairman's
privilege on that i wouldn't oh enjoy
yourself enjoy yourself then feel
in my
remember this always mind on a tuesday
uh well it's not going to be on a
tuesday council bill because that's when
we have our burnham town council meeting
so
that's all
one time please
let me come back um
do you know i forgot why i was going to
say that
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah sorry um
yeah there is a first counselor channel
um
because i just remembered that don't put
me off wait right
uh what we're actually voting for is to
take this to council because council got
to make decisions and i think if it goes
to council with an endorsement from this
committee which looks as though it's
going to be by my job by the way it's
going to be unanimous then yeah that's
great happy by that
thank you so that is um we've all agreed
that i think haven't we agreed but
madame chairman can ask i presume the
live streaming can occur at burnham i
don't see why not okay and the camera is
good that being a problem let's have a
camera set up so yeah okay no i think i
can't see that being a problem at all
which counts is it counselor boys or
counselor
voice i think no cancer jewish madam
chairman it was just to follow on from
what council abel said yes it did used
to be on a tuesday but at times we had
to wait for the town council to finish
its business before we could start
all i was going to do uh uh chairman was
to um uh to agree with councillor fluker
that this will be a recommendation to
the council
uh um
so that is the resolution then
super so members thank you all so much
for
contributions tonight and i now draw the
meeting to a close at
7 54 p.m